Dr zaka regarding another important
aspect how Allah subhana wa tala accepts
Toba repentance what are the prequisites
for sincere Toba and could you possibly
Enlighten us with some prophetic
traditions of some of the prophets
making Toba to Allah subhana wa tala
Allah says in the Quran chapter number
66 verse number eight
that you believe turn to Allah with
sincere repentance and there are
basically five prerequisites for Allah
subhana wa taala to accept Toba number
one the person should accept that he's
doing is wrong number two he should
immediately stop it number three should
seek forgiveness from Allah subhana tala
number four he should not commit that
act again and number five if he has
taken something from any other human
being and if he can return it he return
it back for example if he has robbed
some money should turn the money back if
he has taken some wealth you should give
the wealth back if he can undo the harm
he should do it and according
toim he says that repentance is accepted
when the person does not do that evil
act
again and it further helps him to do
good deeds and prevents him from going
back to that act according to imami he
says there are three
prerequisites for any Toba to be
accepted number one he should stop the
ACT what he's doing number two he should
ask for forgiveness number three he
should not do it again and he says there
a fourth requirement if he had done some
harm to any other human being then you
should undo it if you
can and there are various examples in
the
Hadith which give that how people have
asked for forgiveness it's mentioned the
Hadith of say bukari
volume number four in the Book of
Stories of the Prophet Hadith number
3470 that there was a person who had
committed 99
murders so he wants to seek repentance
so he asked the people that how can he
do it so they sent him to a monk so monk
says that you have killed 99
people there's no chance of
forgiveness so that person that murderer
he kills the among too and now he has
committed 100 murders so he goes to
another person and says that I want to
seek repentance so he says that if you
want to seek repentance go to that land
where people are worshiping Allah
subhana wa ta'ala and inshallah you
should leave the land in which you have
committed the crime and go to that land
where people are seeking repentance and
inshallah Allah will grant you
forgiveness so he immediately goes
towards that land but on his way
death takes place and he dies and he
turns his chest towards that village
where people are repenting then both the
Angels the angels of good and the angels
of bad both come and they want to take
him the angel from the heaven say that
we will take him because he want to
repent but the angels from the bad Deeds
the hell they say no he has not
committed a single Good Deed we will
take him so Allah subhana wa tala
intervenes and he asks the village where
people are repenting that it should come
closer to the person who has committed
murder and He
commands to the place where has
committed the crime that it should go
further away so when they measure the
distance they find out that the person
who committed the murder he was one span
closer to the village where people are
repenting so then Allah subhana tal
grants him Jah so this is an example
that a person commits 100 murder and he
wants to repent only the KN of repenting
and traveling towards that place and a
different version of the same Hadith
says that while dying he pushes himself
towards the he looks towards the place
where he can get forgiveness so this
shows that only the Nia and the
intention to ask for forgiveness Allah
forgives there is another example in say
Muslim Vol number three in the book of H
Hadith number
4207 there's a lady from the type of
Jena she comes to the the
prophet and she had committed adultery
and she was pregnant so she comes to the
prophet and says that I have done so and
so sin please give me
punishment so the prophet calls her
master and it says take care of this
woman till she delivers the child and
after that get her to me so the master
takes care of her and after she gives
birth to her child he gets the woman
then the Prophet says because of the
adultery she has to be given the H
penalty and the lady she has to wrap
around herself with her cloth and the
people Stone her to death and after she
dies the prophet he prays for her so
Omar pleas with him says that oh Prophet
you're praying for a woman who has
committed adultery then the prophet
replies that the way she has repented
even if you distribute this repentance
to 70 people of Madina it would be
sufficient for them to go to
jenah who can repent better than the
woman who's willing to give her life for
the sake of Allah subhana tala a similar
example is given in say Muslim volume
number three in the book
of H Hadith number
4205 that mab Malik PE with him he come
to the prophet and he says that please
Purify Me The Prophet says V to you go
and ask for forgiveness for Allah
subhana tala and you repent the person
he goes back again he comes and he says
that no messenger please pardon me he
says vote to
you ask for forgiveness of Allah subhana
tala and you repent again the person
goes again he comes for the third time
oh messenger of Allah please Purify Me
He says go away from you ask for
repentance ask for forgiveness of Allah
subhana tala again the fourth time he
comes and says to the prophet please
pardon me the prophet says from
what so ma pleas with him he says that
from
adultery he says are you mad have you
gone
crazy so the person says no I'm not mad
then the prophet asked that are you
drunk did you have Kar did you have wine
so the other people get up and the smell
is more they said no prophet he said
no he said did you really commit
adultery he says yes I've committed
adultery and I want the punishment for
the sin I've have committed so Prophet
asked the people to Stone him and he was
Stone to death after Stone to death
there's a controversy between the
sahabas and the two groups of people one
group of people say that he has been
undone that means it's a Pity that he
will not get M undone the other group
says Allah subhana wa ta'ala has
accepted
with him Allah accepted his repentance
and he shall go to J this happens for
two or 3 days then the Beloved Prophet
comes and then he tells to the sahabas
that pray for Malik because he has
repented for a
sin and if you distribute his repentance
even in a large number of people in a
group of people it would be sufficient
here it shows that the people they
committed a major sin but they repented
they were even willing to have
themselves killed because both these
people knew very well that the
punishment for adultery was death it was
thr to death so here it show that the
high level of tawa they had the sincere
repentance that they from Allah subhana
tala and Allah forgiv them